hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to another impossible let's
play this time featuring the clothespin
challenge in this challenge I will be
playing a rage game and every time I die
I will take one of these pins and attach
it to my face
so let's explore the limits of my own
stupidity and what can only be described
as textbook masochism as you all sit
back and enjoy my suffering alright so I
got about 50 pins here and I don't want
to worry anyone they're only ten pounds
they're not gonna do any permanent
damage and I'm gonna be playing Sonic
unfair which I played back in the hot
sauce challenge but if you recall that
didn't exactly go very well for me but
it helped me shut up everybody does body
to you yeah so I'm hoping it's gonna go
a little better this time because this
video only ends when I either beat the
game completely which is terribly
unlikely I attach all 50 of these to my
face or I simply just run out of phase
space in general you know is I don't
have headphones because I need the extra
clipping area so let's see what happens
yay alright I've wasted enough time
let's get to it let's go once we start
there is no turning back
I forget out of okay first death let's
go I stated not bad at all it's hardly
bad at all I may not have placed that
correctly goddamnit I've totally
forgotten how to play when I did the hot
sauce challenge I just kind of blew
through the first level without actually
looking at anything I think the first
ones okay okay that's another death to
rock up go away run my morale starting
with a lip burial why not the best idea
for this I think I'll actually try to
distribute it a little more calmly oh
yes oh yes winner winner chicken dinner
gonna get agree to go I'm gonna beat
this game already I'm not because it's
really not gonna work out well oh okay
there's a dad right over the way well
yeah I said that starting with a little
burial boy a bad idea so I tried it okay
the ride I'm actually gonna try with the
ear here all that wheels good golf god
damnit what the hell I don't even get a
chance to start yeah don't lower it
well frickle frack you I was in a lot of
pain the last time I did that so how
much you go screw yourself and do a ding
dong down chance here this is gonna be
Oh
nailing it nailing it nail it nailing it
doing it [ __ ]
clapping whistle ass off oh I've a lot
of red marks after that it really
doesn't hurt that much with kind of
building up y'all can pound over a long
area time kind of equals a lot of a lot
of missed oh god Garrett how do I get
through that area that's what I got
stuck on the hot sound like your kind of
hurts right Oh God yeah all ki dokie
there's gotta try to little top lip for
last because I what I need to be able to
talk more I tend to a spending quite a
bit that's rather peculiar on this we
can possibly do to get this over why did
I got died there there like spike there
what do I land here yeah do I even know
tall one I please wait a one two three
four five six wait it I've got 12 death
and I only have Conran's what the hell
happened how did I miss the rent oh god
I'm really gonna run out race aren't I
no real New Rochelle ow ow all God
infringing just a little bit over here
okay well I walked right into that one
ooh I need to move out hood can only
grab that hurts
Oh down here I've done it yeah that's
good that's good that'll do
Oh God looking at the care we'll try to
get this to work oh that real god damn
it I don't even get a chance to do
anything although he does that work I
got a lot of crazy vitals cuz I got a
big job cocktail I get the same damn
thing that I did before honking - y'all
get through this okay starting to hurt
on that ear Oh God down with a your
daughterly is it shut balls out and [ __ ]
did you look good there al I gotta lose
out of those oh god that would really
hurt hey little hero relocate oh good oh
no I wrote it all right God yeah we're
out of crisis here
okay okay okay howdy here is not a good
way through it I gotta uh cuz you I kill
you get a chance to do anything yeah do
I look like a punk princess now good
order north walking I'll go get it
you son of a [ __ ] Oh God outlaw run and
you know what [ __ ] out I can't get ways
a god
ah a good up there just stay there just
stay here until I God I do to go through
this because if I don't ever go to god
dammit I don't get those everyone's
think I was with gravy and I don't can't
handle a little hade and actually
doesn't hurt all that bad you guys wait
think that it hurts it don't leave that
ear part that really hurt
I worry getting like calamari er totally
like that ok guy routes are starting to
hurt a little
I got a order to lift ok are you Holly
now this is go see very well
oh it started
ah God dared another gun twice good
governor and I don't think I am done is
this what it feels like to get a
piercing car carry a kid you concentrate
I'm trying to get lighting cuz you think
you're gonna get to like eyes how I
gotta be able to see ok now it was it a
last night okay the goddess Kali
collectively God dad doesn't strike how
I told you get over there and I get to
there it's gonna fall down
oh goodness attach our like weird the
weird couch I can't exactly talking you
guys can see that i drooling clutter it
now directly Claude cultural is real
like an acupuncture and massage but on
every part of the face there we are
that is Laura Rory taught okay that's
the son of that you one of the senses
wound so it's gonna be harder to talk I
think I old kind of you head so I don't
think I attains intends on you
Oh God are your Oh God how are you guys
are you well I like this lady right ah
da guy I should community another shield
I say that healer because I think
English is left as a national language
so I clearly like a lesser older [ __ ]
grew old foxy to allure articulate
ladder this dairy all the little kids
they're running in here yet
I actually get surprised it doesn't hurt
all that hat did I look like it hurts I
didn't actually I could do this for days
and days assuming you already got
availability to do I live
so it's car al
elegance okay good under the client or
under Hong Kong get down I'll hold it
I'll go to the old a good old order
all right on target a 30 you get the
target daughter started got shot
shilling a little lonely you know I
okay a little I rode there your dog
biggest y'all Owen Owen I own her if
that's up there I'll order get that all
yeah okay the GAR oh look a play look
after her oh my god okay yeah you're
stronger you're gonna shuttle attention
all right all right I like God down
dirty dog
all right I got a hoist I think I I
think I literally I don't want to go too
high on that or cuz that actually does
hurt I'll go lower
I got all our guys our guys are good ten
controller strip it's worse than not not
gonna get God Gary I just lost or die
trying to get through this level I think
they know hate it
I do know that I got it I think I got it
don't I go guys go outgo I literally
wrote out of his chest
George okay al oh and get it then I'll
cook clap
gadlight I stir it or cover guys Kersey
they're going to look oh all right her
lurking oh my god
flew right around holy crap I could be
God
der Vaart go auger huh oh it's like a
dehorning Oscar when I get done it it Oh
God
ah ya ya ya ya ya know I look pretty
am i beautiful look at my eyebrows her
friggin oh my god they're marching my
eyebrows I'm gonna be dead honest that
did not that did not hurt all that bad
except when I got to hear this point on
the ears
and I don't want to work
anyone like oh no you don't need a
Hershey's god damn it
ah I can't move my bottom lip ah I need
to shake all the skin back into place
god damn it oh god I have way too much
fun with these things I turning into a
masochist a bit maybe just a little bit
but anyway I hope you guys had a lot of
fun with this one I know I did I wanted
to do more and more of these challenges
so let me know in the comments below
thank you guys so much for watching and
leave a like please if you enjoyed my
suffering here leave a like share this
video with your friends spread the words
about my impossible Let's Plays they're
not gonna ever get dangerous so don't
worry about that but I got another
really cool one lined up very soon
though thanks again for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
hello Ron